today a uk intelligence chief said that
the russian president misjudged his
military's ability to take ukraine
quickly because he was working with bad
information his closest generals and
advisers fearing him so much that they
were afraid to tell him the truth
uk intelligence also reports deplorable
conditions inside the russian military
so bad that soldiers are refusing to
carry out orders and even sabotaging
their own equipment now if putin did not
know all of this six weeks ago when he
ordered the invasion he most certainly
has an idea now
this could explain why the military
claims to be reducing its activity
around the ukrainian capital key
what that means remains to be seen what
we do know is that there has been no let
up in attacks near kiev and further
south in the besieged port city of mario
poll
it is clear putin has no intention of
changing course
we have this report
a month of russian bombardment has
reduced much of mario paul to ruins
while moscow has suffered setbacks
elsewhere in ukraine its efforts to take
the key port have been devastating and
unrelenting
a comparison of satellite imagery from
before the invasion to images from this
week
reveals that almost no building has been
left undamaged
ukrainian officials say more than 90
percent of the city has been destroyed
amidst the ruins
residents are scrambling to survive
we cook what we find among neighbors
a bit of cabbage
some potatoes
we've found tomato paste and some
beetroot
we've been striving for well-being and
now we are dog poor standing by the fire
homeless how long is it going to take we
have nowhere to take a shower we are
drinking water god knows from where
and what kind of bacteria it has
you have to work hard to get good water
[Music]
as the humanitarian situation grows
worse by the day
the mayor of mario paul has repeatedly
called for more help
food and water are running out
we want to call on the international
community to speak out loudly
we want them to unite for just one aim
i'm pleading to them to save the people
here
ukrainian officials say around 5 000
people including over 200 children have
died in mario paul since russia's
assault began
for the residents who remain
there may be a way out soon
ukraine has sent 45 buses to evacuate as
many as possible
[Music]
all right for more now we want to bring
in our correspondent nick connolly he
joins me from keeve good evening to you
nick
let's start with mario paul what are you
hearing about the situation there
tonight
i mean absolute desperation people as we
heard there from the mayor running out
of food trying to get what is still left
in that city with reports of shops being
broken into people trying to find
anything they can because even if they
have money there's nothing open where
they can buy food stories of people
having to bury their nearest and dearest
in their front gardens because the
morgues the whole infrastructure is just
not operating
people without electricity for days at a
time and without internet without mobile
phone connection cut off from the
outside world only a few people with
some satellite phones able to tell the
story of what's happening in mario paul
in the most part we hear what's going on
there from people who've been able to
get out a couple of days later
those are the people who are lucky
enough to have got out to
ukrainian-controlled territory that's
where most people want to go but
increasingly it seems people being put
under pressure by the russian forces
that have taken the suburbs of mariopol
to head to russia often seemingly
against their will um even stories of
those russian authorities taking those
ukrainian people's documents off them
giving them kind of russian pieces of
paper so potentially taking away their
chance of getting back to ukraine later
on
nick what about where you are i mean
we're now in the sixth week
of the russian invasion of ukraine
talk to me about how the mood in the
capital city has changed and evolved in
the past six weeks
well exactly we were here from the start
we were here in those first few days
where most ukrainians weren't sure if
their government would stand whether
president zelinski would take that offer
from the u.s to get out in a hurry
and where the streets were empty and you
could just see panic in people's faces
people trying to work out if it was
better to stay put in their cellars in
the bomb rage shelters in the metro
stations or to get out of the city
either towards the eu or just to kind of
country houses anywhere away from
targets and potential bombing that
definitely has changed there are a lot
more people out on the streets now
people don't scurry away as soon as they
hear the air raid sirens even though
they are living with the kind of
constant background noise of bangs of uh
anti-aircraft systems getting stuff out
of the sky artillery in the distance and
we see those pictures often enough of
housing units on the outskirts of kiev
being hit by russian artillery and
people losing their homes fires people
also losing their lives so in a way
people are getting used to it and are
kind of against the lord's wanting to
kind of hold on to some kind of
normalities cafes are reopening
hairdressing salons and you see people
out it's just unexpected when you see
half the people in camouflage and
they've all got their ak-47s resting
next to their chair in the cafe yeah i
mean i know it it has to be surreal to
actually be there in that there's been
so much talk in the past six weeks of
how this war has unified
nato and the european union what is it
done to the ukrainian nation
well exactly it seems like vladimir
putin is basically achieving all the
things that he says he wants to prevent
by his actions he did it the first time
in 2014 when he
annexed crimea and stoked that conflict
in the east now even more so i was
speaking to someone in kherson in the
south which is near crimea one of the
biggest cities ukraine cities that the
russians have been able to occupy so far
and that the local told me that he was
actually expecting if not a majority but
a significant number of people there in
a russian-speaking region of southern
ukraine to come out and welcome those
russian soldiers and he has not seen any
of it he's seen a few a few
pensioners people with soviet maybe
nostalgia coming out and kind of uh
waving some flags but for the most part
they've been endless demonstrations in
support of ukraine uh the russian forces
controlling city are kind of bemused by
the reception they've got and now it
seems like the ukrainian forces are
actually fighting their way back close
to kerason potentially posed in the next
few days to retake that major city so
definitely a picture here that people
even people locals who had maybe hoped
for what we've seen weren't expecting to
happen
nick let me ask you before we run out of
time about president zielinski he says
that he's prepared
to talk about neutrality prepared to
discuss the status of the donbass region
is that anything other than
considering concessions made under
duress
i think you have to kind of divide
between on the one hand neutrality yes i
think the ukrainians are increasingly
coming to
a kind of sense that nato is not going
to take them in a hurry that basically
they might have to be finland for a few
decades maybe inside the eu but outside
nato nato certainly not doing much to
dispel them of that impression um as for
the donbas well i think he might make
some con some concessions over the
states of the russian language on a
local level but he said quite clearly
that there are going to be no
concessions on ukraine's territorial
integrity he's not going to recognize
russian ownership of crimea let alone
recognize those self-proclaimed
republics in the east so for now i think
those are definitely red lines he's
going to try and distract a bit with
some concessions on the smaller stuff
but for now given ukraine's military
successes i can't see how he or the
ukrainian populace would kind of put up
with more significant concessions
towards vladimir putin's kremlin
nick connolly for us tonight reporting
from keeve as we start
yet another week in this war nick thank
you
russian president vladimir putin using
energy as a weapon today putin demanded
that foreign buyers of russian natural
gas pay in rubles starting this friday
now whether or not putin will carry
through with this ultimatum is unclear
what is certain tonight there are
worries that this could be the beginning
of major energy shortages here in europe
russian gas is still flowing into europe
but that could all be about to change
speaking in moscow on thursday russian
president vladimir putin said the west
must start paying in rubles
or else the taps get turned off
in order to purchase russian natural gas
they must open ruble accounts in russian
banks
it is from these accounts that gas
payments will be made
if such payments are not made we will
consider this a default on the part of
the buyers with all of the ensuing
consequences
nobody sells us anything for free and we
are not going to do charity work
therefore in that case existing
contracts will be stopped
german chancellor ola schultz said
germany would continue to pay in euros
and sometimes dollars
germany's economy minister had stronger
words
with regard to the threat demand or
consideration
one doesn't know what to call it anymore
to be made to pay in rubles
it is crucial for us that the contracts
are respected
it's important for us not to give a
signal that we will be blackmailed by
putin
with the kremlin's demands set to start
from friday
the rationing of gas could quickly
follow
making the impact of russia's war
felt in homes across europe
we want to get more now from felix
kweitzig he is with the mercada research
institute on global commons and climate
change mr krejcik it's good to have you
on the show let me just ask you we are
just hours away now from this friday
deadline do you expect vladimir putin to
turn off the natural gas to europe
beginning tomorrow
it doesn't look very likely but i can't
really comment on it because i'm
obviously not in the head of vladimir
putin
well what do you think how likely do you
think that it is that we're going to be
faced with that situation
now it's it's we are in a in a situation
of extreme ambiguity so we don't really
know what's happening and we must be
prepared that gas will not be flowing
anymore and that of course will be a
quite dramatic situation for
western europe do you think that germany
and europe are prepared if deliveries
are stopped
we are in a very bad position especially
germany because 55 of german gas supply
comes from russia and that's not easy to
substitute um because of pipelines that
are fixed and that cannot be easily
changed into something else so it may be
a very difficult situation
and you say a difficult situation mr
quincy i'm trying to just get a a grasp
here of what will happen here in
europe's largest economy beginning
tomorrow if the deliveries of natural
gas are stopped i mean
what can you give us a a realistic
description of what could possibly
happen are we talking about huge
sections of industry having to to shut
down or suspend operations
so it won't be an immediate dramatic
situation because current gas supplies
are there and will be enough for the
summer so it won't be an immediate
drastic situation but of course
regarding next winter already
things have to change now and that will
mean like to draw all available options
from increasing supply from other sites
but also from reducing the demand for
sub for gas in house heating but also in
industry so impacts will be fed
immediately yes
do you think it's possible between now
and the start of next winter's heating
season
for
the entire economy of germany to begin
conserving and and saving energy so that
it can maybe compensate for the impact
of undelivered russian natural gas
as i said it's so much gas that all
options have to be drawn that means also
conserving energy especially in heating
to to put down the room temperature by
two three degrees even four degrees and
that will be a major chunk of the
response it will also mean to get
additional supply from other countries
in lng gas
and also it will mean to us to
substitute gas with other sources where
possible for example electricity to get
more electricity from renewables and to
get heating in housing from
heating pumps and so to have other
sources of energy and if we draw all of
these options a response is possible and
the next winter will be uh possibly hard
but it will also be not like a complete
cretastrophe when you say hard what do
you mean what would that look like
now what we're talking about is that we
need gas for heating in germany and also
other urban countries and we need gas
for partially for electricity but most
importantly also for industry so all of
these sectors will be impacted
electricity is possibly easiest to think
about because other sources are
available and heating is much more
difficult but what we can do is to have
a bit cooler rooms so that's a very
effective response actually and many
would agree to that an industry will be
impacted hard and their priorities have
to be set like where gas is most
important for
having industry running
and that's that's the strategy to go for
yeah it's a strategy to prepare for
because as they say winter is coming
felix kreuzing with the mercantile
research institute on global commons and
climate change mr kweitzig we appreciate
your analysis tonight thank you
thank you
and here's a quick look now at some of
the other stories connected to the war
in ukraine u.s president biden will
release up to 180 million barrels of oil
from the country's strategic reserves
now this is aimed at controlling
energy prices which have been rising
steadily especially ever since the u.s
and its allies imposed sanctions on
russia over its invasion of ukraine
vladimir klitschko former boxing world
champion and brother of keeves mayor
vitale
met with germany's economy minister
robert hobbick in berlin today klitschko
was in berlin to appeal for more support
for ukraine from political leaders
including economic military and
humanitarian
aid
ukraine state nuclear company says that
russian forces occupying the
contaminated chernobyl nuclear site have
begun leaving after showing signs of
radiation sickness
russian troops seized control of the
plant shortly after the invasion began
the ukrainian staff have continued to
oversee safety
operations there